imaginemos que tengo un sub espacio de
rm digamos que es un sub espacio
es un sub espacio de r n y también
supongamos que tengo una base b
y digamos que es una base para v
entonces tiene un montón de vectores
aquí de uno de dos hasta de caja
ahora como tengo cada vectores en la
base entonces ud es un sub espacio de
dimensión
en su espacio dimensión acá y ahora como
ves base
eso significa que
cualquier vector que esté en mi psuv
espacio b se puede expresar como una
combinación lineal de vectores de la
base es decir a es igual a una constante
por mi primer vector de la base más otra
constante por mi segundo vector de la
base y así hasta una décima constante
por el cadismo vector del cni base
ahora bien muchas veces he usado la
palabra coordenada en el pasado pero
ahora voy a dar una definición precisa
para hacerlo me voy a fijar en los
coeficientes en estos coeficientes de la
combinación lineal de elementos de la
base que me del vector a y voy a llamar
a c1 c2 hasta seca los voy a llamar
amar
al ingresar a otro color las coordenadas
coordenadas de mi vector
con respecto a la base con respecto a mi
base de entonces es con respecto a ver y
cuando quiera decir que voy a escribir
un vector a partir de sus coordenadas
entonces lo que voy a hacer es escribir
mi vector
y para enfatizar el hecho de que las
coordenadas están relacionadas con la
base de lo que hago es encierro mi
vector en paréntesis cuadrados
pongo mi conjunto base aquí el conjunto
b
y escribo
escribo precisamente los coeficientes de
la combinación lineal en orden recuerden
que d es una base ordenada
entonces pongo los coeficientes de la
combinación lineal en orden según 12 2
hasta c
ahora algo que resulta bastante
interesante aquí algo que es muy
interesante es que ve es un sub espacio
de rn entonces cualquier vector que esté
en fe también está en rn
es una base que sólo consiste en cada
elementos ahora sí acá es menor a n
entonces digamos por ejemplo podría ser
que podría ser un plano en r3 entonces
de la base b sólo tendría dos vectores y
para especificar algo que está en
nuestro psuv espacio solo necesito usar
acá coordenadas o sea no importa que a
sea un miembro de rn para especificar lo
dentro del psuv espacio solo necesito
dar acá posiciones distintas
digamos que le estoy dando posiciones
dentro del psuv espacio entonces no
importa que sean menos bueno quizás ésta
se aclare un poco más con un ejemplo así
que vamos a bajar acá vamos a bajarnos
un poco imaginemos que tengo dos
vectores en r2 de uno que va a ser mi
vector 2 1
y digamos que también tengo v2 que va a
ser el vector 12 12 los pongo en enredos
para que sean fáciles de visualizar
y algo que puede resultar o no evidente
es que b1 b2 el conjunto b que contiene
a b1 b2 es una base es una base para r2
y esto significa que cualquier vector
que esté en r2 se puede representar como
una combinación lineal de b1 y b2
otra cosa que podemos observar es que r2
tiene dimensión 2 y la base de 1 b 2
contiene dos elementos que son
linealmente independientes para ver qué
b1 y b2 son linealmente independientes
como la matriz 2 1 1 2 y mediante
transformaciones elementales la
convierto en la matriz identidad 1 0 0 1
eso automáticamente me dice que los
vectores b1 y b2 son linealmente
independientes y como son dos forman una
base para ir de 12 vamos a también hacer
una gráfica vamos a visualizar cómo se
ven estos vectores en el plano así que
voy a tomar mis dos ejes voy a tomar
primero déjenme luego en otro color que
contraste más voy a tomar primero mi eje
vertical
y vertical y también voy a tomar mi eje
horizontal
bien entonces el b1 el 21 se ve dos
unidades a la derecha y una para arriba
así que está más o menos a y ese es mi
vector de 1 así que ese es mi b 1 ahora
1000 b 2 se ve algo así es el 12
así que una unidad a la derecha y subo
dos unidades y el vector más o menos
está por ahí ok entonces para
ejemplificar esto de las coordenadas voy
a tomarme un tercer vector y voy a darlo
como una combinación lineal de b1 y b2
para hacer las cosas más sencillas
déjenme tomar por ejemplo el vector que
sea tres veces b 1 3 veces de uno más
dos veces dos veces b 2 bien y que
vector es este pues tengo que hacer esta
operación tres veces por b uno es tres
por dos más dos veces por la primera
coordenada db2 es
3 x 2 + 2 x 1 que es 8 luego 3 veces x
uno más dos veces por dos o sea tres más
43 más 47 así que tengo el vector 87 y
dónde está este vector en el plano qué
posición me termina pues me muevo 8
unidades a la derecha con unidades a la
derecha y luego tengo que subir 7
unidades
así que más o menos tendría una flecha
del origen a este punto otro amo decirlo
es que el vector me específica este
punto el punto que si hablamos de las
coordenadas viejitas las que siempre
usamos es el punto 8,7
y si quisiera dibujar el vector como ya
dije es una flecha que va del origen a
este punto ahora bien yo ya tengo dada
la base de la base b que consiste en el
vector b1 y b2 así que la pregunta es
cómo le hago para expresar al vector 87
en términos de esta base digamos que
llamó este lector el vector a entonces
tengo que el vector a es el vector 87
entonces yo ya sé qué combinación lineal
de la base me da el vector a es
simplemente la combinación que es tres
veces b uno más dos veces b dos y eso me
da el 87 en otras palabras si quisiera
escribir el vector a con coordenadas
respecto a la base b que voy a poner
también aquí en azul con el vector a con
respecto a la base b es igual a los
coeficientes de la combinación lineal en
orden así que es 32
un argumento visual que apoya esta
definición es el siguiente imagínense
que tenemos un nuevo sistema ordenado
antes en las coordenadas viejitas lo que
teníamos eran direcciones horizontales y
verticales y tenemos marcas de unidad en
cada eje entonces teníamos dos
direcciones y mediamos ciertas
longitudes ahora lo que tenemos son dos
nuevos vectores
las coordenadas lo que me dicen son
múltiplos de cada vector de la base por
ejemplo la primera coordenadas son
múltiplos de b1 a ello tengo una vez por
ver un símil o dos veces de uno llegaría
al 42 que estaría más o menos por ahí
tres veces por b uno sería el 63 que
sería
pongo marcas en los ejes 4 6 y 8
entonces el 63 estaría más o menos por
ahí eso es tres veces b 14 veces de 1
nos llevaría al 84 y creo que ya se
están dando la idea de lo que pasa lo
que podemos imaginar es que entregamos
uno de los ejes como si el eje
horizontal lo hubiéramos movido y
tuviéramos un eje generado por la
dirección de v1 entonces más o menos
tenemos un eje que se va por ahí y
continúa del otro lado
y la coordenada lo que me dice es
cuántos múltiplos de v1 debo recorrer
entonces simplemente son las marcas son
incrementos de unidad de longitud de uno
y dirección de uno obviamente
a la segunda coordenada lo que me dice
es cómo moverme respecto a b2 entonces
aquí tengo una vez por b 2 2 veces de 2
estaría por ahí tres veces b 2 tenía más
o menos por ahí
y etcétera entonces de nuevo puedo
considerar una especie de eje generado
por dedos o key entonces la idea es que
más o menos tengo esta cuadrícula entre
cada y de nuevo tengo una especie de
líneas guías como en una cuadrícula
normal entonces las coordenadas me dicen
cómo moverme para que combinando los
movimientos en dirección b1 y en
dirección b2 llegar a mi punto original
si ponemos estas líneas díaz déjenme
pongo estas líneas guías que en este
caso estas amarillas son paralelas al
vector b2
más o menos por ahí voy a tratar de que
salga bien para que puedan entender el
concepto fácilmente
ahí está quizás debido haber usado la
herramienta de líneas rectas pero es muy
tarde
entonces aquí es lo que estoy haciendo
es como una especie de de papel para
graficar son líneas guías para poder
determinar fácilmente posiciones ok
entonces tengo esta especie de
cuadrícula chueca
y lo que tengo son coordenadas respecto
a esta nueva cuadrícula y que tiene esto
que ver con las coordenadas pues la
primera coordenada me dice cómo moverme
en dirección de uno así que tengo 12 23
de nuevo tres unidades en dirección de
uno y luego tengo que moverme dos en
dirección de dos así que uno dos y si
conecto a esas líneas guías llegó
exactamente al punto 87 en el plano lo
que hice fue moverme tres unidades tres
múltiples dv uno en dirección de uno y
luego sumar dos múltiplos de v2 en
realidad también me podría haber movido
dos unidades en dirección de dos y luego
tres unidades en dirección de uno así
que bueno el vector 87 se expresa en
nuestro nuevo sistema coordinado con las
coordenadas 32 esto quiere decir que es
tres veces b uno más dos veces de dos
simplemente quiere decir que para llegar
al 87 tengo que moverme tres veces en
dirección de 1
y dos veces en dirección de 2
y por eso estas se llaman coordenadas
porque me dicen dónde es la posición de
un punto en relación con dos vectores
guías digamos dos generadores me dicen
cómo moverme para poder llegar al punto
que tenía
ahora una buena pregunta es porque he
estado hablando de coordenadas desde
antes por ejemplo cuando teníamos el
plano y teníamos digamos un vector que
va a ser b no sé
3 digamos r2 3 - 1 este es un buen
vector
y si lo grafica mos xilográfica mos
tenemos aquí están mis ejes un poco
lento dibujando ejes 1 2 3 y luego bajo
y entonces se vería algo así director y
especifica este punto
porque he estado diciendo que este punto
tiene coordenadas tres menos uno
cómo se relaciona esto con la definición
de coordenadas que acabamos de dar
porque esto lo he hecho desde antes de
hacer álgebra lineal no entonces como
relaciono esta definición viejita de
puntos en el plano con esta definición
de coordenadas de vectores respecto a
una base pues resulta que éstas sí son
coordenadas con respecto a una base es
una base especial consideren los
vectores 1 como el 1 0
y el 2,01 entonces resulta que estos
vectores son linealmente independientes
y de hecho si dijera sea ese el conjunto
de uno
2 entonces ese es es la llamada base
estándar de base estándar
para r2d2 y esto se llama base estándar
porque estos 24 son ortogonales y es una
de la dirección horizontal y 1 en la
dirección vertical entonces cualquier
vector cualquier vector en el plano
digamos un vector xy
se puede expresar como combinación
lineal de 1 y 2 simplemente es x por uno
más y por 2 y los invito a verificar
esto es una cuenta muy muy sencilla
entonces qué pasa si quisiera escribir
el vector x y xi en coordenadas con
respecto a la base estándar entonces lo
encierro en paréntesis cuadrados pongo
la base estándar
y qué coordenadas tiene pues son los
coeficientes de esta combinación lineal
y cuáles son esos coeficientes en orden
pues precisamente el coeficiente de mi
primer básico
x y el coeficiente mi segundo básico es
así que las coordenadas del vector xy
respecto a la base estándar son x d
entonces realmente las coordenadas que
habíamos usado antes son un caso
particular de las de ahora simplemente
son coordenadas ordenadas con respecto
respecto a la base estándar de r2 que es
simplemente la base que les puse por
hallar la base conformada por los
vectores 1 y el 2 también podríamos
decir que estas son las coordenadas
estándar
con tronadas estándar y solo quería
enseñarles cómo las coordenadas que
habíamos estado usando las coordenadas
que hablamos de puntos en el plano no es
una definición inconsistente con las
coordenadas vistas como coeficientes en
una combinación lineal simplemente era
en el caso particular en el que la base
la base que tomábamos era la base
estándar tr2